le discours nucléaire du président
Poutine est dangereux et irresponsable
nous prenons au sérieux ces menaces et
restons vigilants mais nous ne nous
laisserons pas intimider
un recours aux armes nucléaires
changeraient fondamentalement la nature
du conflit et aurait des conséquences
graves
la Russie c'est qu'une guerre nucléaire
ne peut pas être gagnée et ne doit
jamais être mené
cette nouvelle conférence de presse de
yens toltenberg qui met en garde la
Russie il y aura de graves conséquences
en cas d'attaque nucléaire sur l'Ukraine
bon ça reste bien sûr flou et vague
c'est normal volontairement parce que le
principe de dissuasion nucléaire et a
fortiori dans ce cas de figure où il y
aurait un emploi différencié selon le
camp consiste à ne pas dire à l'autre ce
que l'on va faire contrairement à
Vladimir Poutine qui semble-t-il dans un
moment finalement peut-être non pas des
gaments mais dans un moment de peur a
tenu à dire et en disant on affirmant on
a oui en appuyant la chose par ce n'est
pas du bluff que la Russie utiliserait
le nucléaire tactique qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que de l'autre
côté on est dans une configuration
d'abord où on se demande ce que l'on
emploie en premier si la Russie emploie
un engin une bombe tactique sur le
territoire ukrainien on répond de
manière conventionnelle jusqu'à présent
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait le coup
d'après c'est encore ça c'est ça qui est
le plus important c'est à dire que si on
répond à la Russie dans un premier temps
et que la Russie ne tiennent pas compte
ne tient pas compte de cet avertissement
et qu'elle continue par exemple quel
emploi un deuxième
engin de nucléaire tactique qu'est-ce
qu'on fait à ce moment-là et là
effectivement il y a une interrogation
qui n'est pas résolue pour l'instant au
sein de l'OTAN et cela explique aussi la
raison pour laquelle staltenberg est peu
bavard sur la question parce que vous
avez des dissensions au sein de non
seulement de l'OTAN mais de l'Union
européenne je donne un exemple Emmanuel
Macron hier a dit la France interviendra
pas alors et pour cause la France en
terme de nucléaire possède le
stratégique c'est à dire le ce qui est
capable au fond de de rayer un pays
entier de la carte mais
c'est une chose mais de l'autre côté que
se passerait-il si
l'OTAN décidé une action ferme contre la
Russie c'est-à-dire par exemple des
installations de l'armée qu'elles soient
en Ukraine ou éventuellement en Russie
ça serait très grave et dans ce cas-là
il faudrait s'assurer que cette frappe
soit radicale c'est pourquoi le
la personne chargée de de des Affaires
étrangères en Europe José Borel dit
aujourd'hui si nous agissions de la
sorte nous nous arrangerions pour que
l'ensemble de l'armée russe soit anéanti
ce qui est très grave mais qui en même
temps montre le fait que quand vous
voulez frapper il faut que l'autre ne
puisse plus frapper or dans le cas du
stratégique c'est effectivement la
dissuasion qui marche c'est-à-dire on
vous dit je vais vous frapper vous
frapper et vous vous dites je frapperai
aussi il n'y aura plus personne donc
vous voyez c'est ça la différence entre
le stratégique et le tactique c'est que
dans le tactique malheureusement on tue
effectivement phrase on peut raser une
région on peut tuer 200000 personnes 300
000 mais le reste survit dans le cas
d'une stratégique ça n'est pas
précisément ça n'est pas le cas donc si
vous voulez pour essayer de sortir de ce
problème on entend beaucoup parler et
les Ukrainiens l'ont demandé
l'installation l'instauration d'une
protection suffisamment
apte à déjouer ou à carrément détruire
les missiles envoyés ou les les les obus
envoyer par les Russes et là bien sûr on
pense aux dômes de fer que possède
Israël pour le Proche-Orient simplement
le problème c'est ce qu'on signalé un
certain nombre de responsables
militaires israéliens il n'est pas
adapté à ce type de guerre c'est-à-dire
vu la puissance des engins russes le
Dôme de fer israélien tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui n'est pas exportable sur le
terrain
ukrainien donc ça veut dire que cette
possibilité théorique qu'il y aurait à
contrer les missiles russes et les
engins russes pour que justement on
n'est pas à répondre c'est à dire pour
que il n'y ait pas de de finalement de
prétexte pour répondre pour que l'OTAN
réponde et bien cette hypothèse là ne
peut pas être avancée pour une
utilisation immédiate et puis par
ailleurs il reste toujours l'hypothèse
l'hypothèque de la part de la Russie
d'employé un engin sale c'est-à-dire
nucléaire tactique ou éventuellement
même bactériologique ou chimique mais
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de nous
les occidentaux tomber dans le piège des
des Russes qui ont commencé à parler de
la menace nucléaire et puis ensuite Joe
Biden a répondu en disant qu'il y a le
risque d'une apocalypse il a eu tort
alors il a eu tort peut-être de
s'emballer sur la sur les normalité de
la chose mais si vous voulez l'habitude
qu'à Poutine de l'Occident c'est-à-dire
l'habitude en Géorgie l'habitude sur la
Crimée d'autres encore c'est précisément
d'insister à un concert de protestation
de la part de l'Occident mais qui ne va
pas plus loin et c'est comme ça que
Poutine à avancé et c'est comme ça qu'il
avancerait qu'il continuera à avancer si
par exemple on disait aussi négociation
maintenant négociation Poutine dirait
bon bah voilà je peux je peux tirer mon
épingle du jeu de toute manière les
Occidentaux sont comment cette fatigués
là comme on dit de cette campagne et
bien ils vont céder sur la plupart de
mes revendications et la prochaine fois
j'irai plus loin c'est là-dessus que
compte Poutine donc si vous voulez le
fait de
disons d'être dans la compréhension de
ce que veut Poutine n'oblige pas à se
coucher devant lui ni même d'aller
jusqu'à l'escalade puisqu'encore une
fois l'OTAN maintient le mystère sur sa
réaction mais dit simplement abouti
cette fois-ci cette fois-ci ça ne
marchera pas cette fois-ci vous agirez
et nous nous répondrons d'une manière
ferme alors on sait pas ce que sera
cette manière ferme si jamais
malheureusement elle devait intervenir
mais c'est une façon si vous voulez
politique là de dire ce coup-là on ne
marche plus alors qu'il faut espérer
c'est que précisément ça soit le cas
parce que sinon on arrive au désastre
syrien vous vous souvenez ou Obama
avez-vous lu frapper finalement la ligne
rouge la fameuse ligne rouge qui a été
franchie par par Damas et qui n'a pas
donné lieu à des bombardements alors
qu'à l'époque le pouvoir français lui
était prêt à aller c'est-à-dire à
frapper Bachar al-Assad directement et
ça va entraîner la l'entrée en guerre
des Russes aux côtés de Bachard avec les
succès qu'ils ont obtenus et surtout la
formation finalement l'expérience qu'ils
ont gagné en Syrie qui s'a ppliquent
aujourd'hui à l'Ukraine